-Our next guest is a talented
actor and comedian
you know from his work on
"Saturday Night Live"
and "30 Rock" and animated shows
such as "Archer"
and "Rick and Morty."
He stars in "Senior Year", which
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-You want a beer?
-Oh, uh...sure.
-Bah! Wrong answer, hot rod.
You think I'm gonna let you
drink and drive
with my daughter?
-Oh, well,
I'm actually not driving.
We're taking a Lyft.
-Oh, cool.
Though I suspect Stephanie would
prefer not to spend her prom
evening with a drunken fool.
-Well, it'll just be the --
Uh, no, I think I'm okay,
actually.
Maybe have a water if anything.
-Did you bring some condoms?
-[ Gulps ]
Um, no.
-Hmm. Didn't think we need to
have this talk.
But, uh, Seth, you are aware
that unprotected sex
can lead to
geriatric pregnancies?
-Stephanie --
-You ready to be an old dad?
-I'm sorry. Do you want me to
sleep with your daughter or --
-What did you just ask me?
-Please welcome to the show
our good friend
Chris Parnell, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome. It's so wonderful
to have you here.
-Thank you.
It's wonderful to be here.
-Yeah, back at 30 Rock,
where we first met.
This is a fantastic film with
Rebel Wilson.
She plays a woman who's come out
of a 20-year coma
and is now going through
her senior year.
-Yes, she's determined
to go back
and finish out her senior year.
-And you play her father.
And had you ever worked with
Rebel before?
She's sort of a force of nature.
-I hadn't, but she is.
But she's also just like a cool,
normal, real person, you know?
But she's so funny.
I mean, some of the stuff --
When we were shooting,
there's a scene where I take
her phone away, and she fights
it very vehemently.
And when we were shooting it,
I thought to myself, "That was
probably a little over the top."
I just kept it to myself.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Eh, that's too
much, that's too much.
Take it down a notch."
But then when I saw it, I was
like, "Oh, no, she was right.
That's brilliant."
-She knows what she's doing.
-It's hilarious. Yeah.
-You actually taught high school
for a year after --
after college you went back?
-Mm-hmm. Yeah.
-I'm assuming
you taught theater.
-I did. I taught at my old high
school, Germantown High School.
Taught introduction to theater
and introduction to
film and video.
-Gotcha.
-Classes I had taken.
And yeah, I mean, I loved
working with all the kids who
were involved with the theater
department and the TV studio
because that's what I did,
and those are the really
dedicated students.
I wasn't so cut out
for the day-to-day teaching.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Does that mean there were kids
in your class --
some of your classes, who maybe
weren't as invested in it?
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it was like there would
be a group of students who are
very dedicated just 'cause they
wanted good grades
or whatever --
they were serious students.
Then there's the sort of the
bulk of them that were like,
"Oh, okay, I'll kinda try."
And then there are a few that
are just, like, determined to
make my life hell, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-And do you think --
'Cause that's a young age
to be a teacher.
I would assume you were kind of
like blood in the water.
They knew they had something.
-It's true, very much.
And I floundered.
Much like now, I have no idea
how to maintain discipline
with my own kids.
I certainly didn't then.
[ Laughter ]
-And then you --
Sort of your path to
your comedy career was to L.A.
and then you did
the Groundlings,
a very famous comedy theater
in L.A.
And you actually were roommates
with a pre-"SNL" Kristen Wiig?
-That's right, yeah.
-How did you guys end up
as roommates?
-Her roommate at the time,
Holly Mandel, was coming to
New York for a bit, and I was
going to L.A. for a bit,
so Holly stayed in my place
and I stayed in her bedroom.
-And how quickly did you --
Could you have any sense of
those days of like, "Oh, my God,
Kristen Wiig is something else"?
-Well, I mean,
she was pretty funny.
-Yeah.
-She was pretty fun.
It was completely platonic.
But, yeah, it was just a fun --
it was a fun few months
or whatever.
I remember taking pictures of
each other
under the kitchen cabinets,
like hiding in there.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a very --
I will say that's a very --
For anybody knows Kristen Wiig,
that's a very Kristen Wiig
thing, that she would get
an idea of like, "Here's we're
gonna do tonight.
We're gonna take pictures that
make it look like
we're in the kitchen cabinets."
-Right.
-And it would be
like an eight-hour bit, yeah.
-But we really were
in the kitchen cabinets.
-Oh, there you go.
Yeah, you guys never cheated it.
That was the thing about
you guys.
-No, that was it.
-You had a nickname at "SNL"
I remember hearing
when I showed up,
which was "Ice Man,"
which both referred to the fact
that you would execute a script
sort of word perfectly, no
flubs, but also you never --
You famously never broken
sketches, including maybe
what is the hardest to believe
of all time --
You were in "Cowbell" and were
the only member of "Cowbell"
who kept it together.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I mean, that's really, like,
that's the gold standard of
not breaking because I think,
when you go back and watch it,
it seems like Will's sole
purpose in that sketch
was to make his castmates break.
-I think it was.
I think it was. Yeah.
Christopher Walken and I
did not break.
-That's right.
-Although there was a moment
that the camera was not on me,
and I knew it wasn't on me,
and I looked down at my guitar,
and I smiled.
So I don't know if that counts
as a break.
-That, like, speaks to your
nobility as a performer that
you want to let us know like,
"I wasn't perfect off-camera."
-I wasn't.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not really the Ice Man.
-It's weird.
It never even occurred to me
that Christopher Walken
also didn't break 'cause just
the idea of Christopher Walken
breaking is, like,
so crazy to me.
-It's impossible.
-Yeah.
'Cause I, in my head, he just --
That whole sketch
is that character.
He's never a guy who's, like,
judging whether or not
this is a funny sketch.
-No, he's right there.
He's in it. He is that guy.
-You've been doing a lot of V.O.
work as well.
"Archer."
Another season of "Archer"?
-We're waiting to hear,
you know. We got season 13
that I don't know
if that's about to come out.
I kind of lose track.
-And "Rick and Morty" as well.
-"Rick and Morty."
[ Audience cheers ]
-There we go.
It must be wonderful,
for both those shows,
when the scripts come in,
because they do -- certainly
from watching them,
it seems like an incredible
amount of care and love
goes into those scripts.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
They're very dense.
You know, even though the show
doesn't last that long,
you know, it's like a lot of
material in there,
and there are a lot of jokes.
And, yeah, they're delightful
to read.
-Like, I mean,
I have always thought
you have a million-dollar voice.
Have you finally moved
to the position
that you have
a great voice-over voice?
-Well, you know what
the thing is?
A lot of voice-overs now,
they don't necessarily want
a voice-over voice guy, you
know, unless you're doing promos
or something like that,
so a lot of the commercial work
is about just sounding like
a normal guy, whatever that is.
[ Laughter ]
-Coming out of you,
it doesn't look normal at all.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You know, we did some sketch
work together, not a lot, but we
were in "Appalachian Emergency
Room" written by Paula Pell.
[ Laughter ]
You played a character
named Tyler.
-That's right.
-And Tyler often was in
the Appalachian emergency room
for a pretty specific reason.
-Yeah. He got a lot of things
stuck up
in his rear behind area.
[ Laughter ]
-And often kind of went out of
his way to explain
how it had been
a total accident.
-It was a very elaborate
explanation.
-Yeah. But not particularly easy
to believe, but elaborate.
-Never.
-We talk about Second Chance
Theatre here with my old "SNL"
castmates, something they did
that maybe fell a little flat
in front of the audience.
-Right.
-Of your work, what would you
propose to get the Second Chance
Theatre treatment?
-Oh, my goodness, wow.
There definitely were some "SNL"
sketches that I think I could
have bumped up a little better.
There was one I did
for Andrew Steele.
Andrew Steele wrote it.
-Yep.
-And it was Steve Baxter,
Hollywood gynecologist.
[ Laughter ]
And Bill Murray was the host.
He was the gynecologist.
And I was, like, a jazzy lounge
singer guy singing about him.
And there's one moment in it
where it was just kind of
a musical break.
And I wanted to do this thing,
like, I'd be like, "Ooh-ooh-ah,"
a guy really feeling the music
and all that.
And Lorne,
between dress and air, told me,
"Don't do that thing
with your head."
[ Laughter ]
And I remember being tormented
by it.
I was talking to Tina Fey.
I was like, "But that's my best
moment in it."
And so I ended up doing it.
[ Laughter ]
And I think it was a mistake.
-Well, you know what?
It's nice that you can look back
and have that judgment.
Yeah, yeah.
Every now and then, we make
the wrong call in the moment.
-You got to listen to Lorne.
Hey, congratulations
on the film.
Thanks so much for being here.
It's always so great to see you.
-Thanks for having me.
-Chris Parnell, everybody.
"Senior Year" is currently
streaming on Netflix.
We'll be right back with
Kwame Onwuachi.